pour atteindre le temps poule où la
coupe qui contient le sang de
jésus-christ réside à jamais le
lionheart professeur jones depuis des
temps immémoriaux il est un symbole
prospérant le courage et la force en
1519 un ancêtre du go connu sous le nom
dargaud rock pourrait trouver cette
fameuse divinité avant de soudainement
disparaître
depuis les chercheurs n'ont plus trouvé
aucune trace du liner tu ta part une
énigme non résolus quiconque trouve le
'lion' earth accédera son pouvoir
et voici d'énigmes découverte par nos
chercheurs
celui qui souhaite marcher dans les pas
du coeur du lyon devra faire preuve de
réflexion
trois mots mystérieux à trouver
permettront d'en révéler un dernier pour
le premier mot on être certain et sa
définition
c'est aussi un verbe traduisons la
religion
la détermination est un synonyme du
second mot ne jamais abandonner garder
allumée votre flambeau le troisième mot
pourrait être qualifié de cibles
nous en avons tous un plus vous
avancerez plus il sera visible ces trois
palabres fusionner permettront
d'atteindre à pouvoir tant convoité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
une saga qui m'a passionné durant toute
mon enfance
j'aimerais aujourd'hui vous parler d'
indiana jones mais pas n'importe lequel
j'aimerais vous parler du cinquième opus
de la série prévue pour 2019 harrison
ford est motivé malgré ses 75 ans passés
à renfiler le costume du célèbre
archéologue henry jones junior
mais avant de commencer je vais vous
donner plus d'éclaircissements sur
l'énigme proposée vous devez retrouver
trois mois dans cette énigme ces trois
mots ont tous un point commun et peuvent
donc en former plus qu'un seul le mois
retrouvée et donc est la clé pour
accéder au live earth si vous trouvez ce
mot vous avez donc le mail caché qu'il
faut pour gagner car le mot à trouver
permet de trouver une adresse mail est
le premier à m'envoyer un mail dessus
aura réussi le mot @ hotmail.fr sans
accent sans espace sentirait et cetera
merci d'ailleurs de tout coeur à rsf
d'avoir fait la voix off de l'intro nous
reparlerons de sa chaîne à la fin de la
vidéo
bref je vais donc improviser une fois de
plus apprenti scénariste en essayant
d'imaginer ce qui pourrait se passer
dans ce prochain opus
mais d'abord posons les bases que
savons-nous sur ce prochain film est
bien quasiment rien et c'est la
complexité du sujet mais plusieurs
éléments peuvent nous orienter vers de
potentiel indices en premier lieu
rappelez-vous dit diana jones 4 avec le
mystère du crâne de cristal
nous étions en pleine période de guerre
froide et henry devait faire face aux
soviétiques
l'histoire du film se passait vers la
fin des années 50 donc nous serons à peu
près dans les années 60 pour le
cinquième épisode de la saga
de plus il serait apparemment dick
indiana jones 5 serait une suite directe
à l'opus cat
mais bon rien n'est sûr mais c'est une
information qui tourne beaucoup
enfin les quêtes dit diana jones tourne
toujours autour de célèbres mystère
connu dans le monde
l'arche de l'alliance le crâne de
cristal ou bien même la quête du graal
il nous faut donc un mystère tournant
autour d'un objet symbolique et
historique avec justement un contexte
tournant autour de l'époque des années
plusieurs mystères sont d'ailleurs
rajouté est liée à la quête de l'objet
recherché comme par exemple la zone 51
ou les géoglyphes de nasca dans l'opus 4
voyons ce que l'on peut dégager de tout
ça avec les trois théories que je vous
propose
[Musique]
remettons nous dans le contexte nous
sommes début années 60
donc suite à indiana jones 4 et quel
événement important s'est passé durant
cette période
bien évidemment la guerre du vietnam le
conflit durera entre 1955 et 75 et
oppose à la république démocratique du
vietnam soit le côté nord vietnamiens et
le front national de libération du sud
vietnam le nord contre le sud
je ne vais pas vous résumer la guerre du
vietnam car cela prendrait trop de temps
mais il faut savoir que les etats-unis
soutenaient le vietnam sud et la chine
et l'urss au côté nord nous sommes
toujours en période de guerre froide la
réelle guerre commença vers 63 et
collerait parfaitement pour indiana
jones 5
les films d'indiana jones se base
toujours sur un conflit militaire comme
les états unis contre les allemands dans
la seconde guerre où les soviétiques
pendant la guerre froide
les années 60 sont réellement marqué par
la guerre du vietnam et je pense que
l'histoire d' indiana jones 5 pourrait
se passer durant ce conflit pour
continuer j'aimerais vous parler
maintenant d'une légende vietnamienne
qui pourrait prendre un sens particulier
pour le prochain jenna jones la légende
de la tortue d'or
selon la légende les taillis au début de
sa lutte aurait reçu d'un pêcheur une
été repêché dans le lac
dix ans plus tard après avoir réussi à
chasser les chinois grâce à cette
mystérieuse épais et traversant ce même
lac
il est abordé par la tortue d'or qui lui
réclame l'épée au nom du roi dragon
ancêtres mythiques du peuple viêt l'état
y comprend alors que l'épée était un
mandat du ciel pour chasser les chinois
du pays
malheureusement nous sommes en 1963
environ et les moyens de la guerre ont
énormément évolué notamment avec les
engins aériens comme les hélicoptères
qui apparaissent pour leur première fois
dans ces conflits mais aussi le napalm
donc bon une épée magique ne serait pas
bien menaçants
cependant une autre légende compte
dans cette tortue pourrait quant à elle
bien marché et créer une bonne histoire
d'après cette légende un autre roi du
nom de and zoom bang aurait reçu une
sorte d'arc aux arbalètes magique lui
permettant de défaire l'armée chinoise
d'une assez grande facilité
cependant un prince vietnamiens du nom
de sanctuary provenant du camp ennemi
perdant de la guerre c'est dû à la fille
du roi à nzeng ayong possesseurs de
l'arbalète magique et devint son
conseiller intime et c'est là que la
théorie entre en jeu car leur voix
montre à son arbalète de plus près à 106
et lui expliqua qu'elle était magique
car la gâchette était constitué d'une
griffe de la tortue doré malheureusement
il n'aurait jamais dû lui faire
confiance aux cartes 36 pendant un
moment d'inadvertance vole à la griffer
la remplaça par une fausse il prétexte à
un mensonge pour rentrer dans son
royaume qui suite au vol de la griffe
attaquera sans tarder le royaume de au
lac propriété du roi à zeng guang son
arme n'était donc plus magique
il décida de s'enfuir avec sa fille et
implorant l'aide de la tortue d'or qui a
paru sans tarder
cette dernière lui montre à ceux
d'autres raisons de sa fille qui laissa
des plumes sur son chemin pour que son
amant la retrouve à tsonga
vang tu as donc sa fille est suivie la
tortue d'or dans la mer 38 se suicida
suite au décès de sa bien-aimée ne
supportant pas la douleur
cette légende est réellement intéressant
dans le cadre du prochain gala jones
les américains seront en guerre contre
les vietnamiens dans les années 60 et
chaque camp cherchera la victoire
cependant afin de s'assurer de la
victoire les vietnamiens pourrait
envoyer un groupe de chercheurs pour se
mettre en quête de cette fameuse grippe
de la tortue d'or qui permet donc au
final de rendre une arme totalement
dévastatrice le professeur jones
connaissant cette légende se mettraient
en route pour obtenir la griffe avant
les vietnamiens et donc éviter un
massacre américain des plus effroyables
imaginez si cette griffe peut s'allier
aux armes à feu ou bien encore tout
autre artillerie c'est une course contre
la montre pour éviter une destruction
totale des vies de millions de gens et
indiana jones n'aurait pas le droit à
l'erreur c'est un cadre réellement
intéressant pour ce prochain film et qui
conserverait donc le même schéma que ses
prédécesseurs
entre la course contre lézina pour pas
dire le vrai mot avec l'arche de
l'alliance
valve avec walter donovan et lézina
encore une fois ou bien les soviétiques
avec le crâne de cristal n'avons encore
jamais eu de film en rapport avec le
vietnam qui fut pour la partie du nord
un ennemi entre guillemets des états
unis tout est donc fait pour que le
cinquième film puisse correspondre
n'hésitez pas à me dire ce que vous en
pensez dans les commentaires
[Musique]
dans cette deuxième théorie nous allons
partir pour mexico complètement à
l'opposé de la théorie précédentes car
j'aurais peut-être une idée de scénario
probable pour la suite soudaine d'
indiana jones 4 parce qu'apparemment le
5 serait potentiellement une suite
directe de son prédécesseur
amnon la théorie si vous ne vous
souvenez plus d' indiana jones et le
crâne de cristal le crâne de cristal
était le fragment manquant sur treize
que l'aide de cristal qui permettait à
un être supérieur de retrouver la vie et
s'en aller cet être en question n'était
pas seul à la base et il était dit qu'il
avait apporté le savoir au peuple
primitif soit l'agriculture la roue et
cetera ils en savent d'ailleurs
énormément sur l'histoire du monde
le professeur spall qu en a d'ailleurs
fait les frais à trop vouloir en savoir
bref pour en revenir à la théorie si
indiana jones 5 serait une suite sous
les nos 4 on pourrait avoir encore une
histoire tournant autour des
extraterrestres ou autres êtres
supérieurs et j'ai un scénario fait de
mes mains rien pour vous parlons de la
cité de teotihuacan située au nord est
de mexico ainsi très anciens ou deux
pyramides principal est gigantesque ont
été bâties la pyramide de la lune et la
pyramide du soleil
cependant attention je tiens tout
d'abord à vous prévenir que je ne vais
pas détailler le lieux complet ainsi que
tous ses mystères carence s'écarterait
du but de la vidéo soyons alors direct
d'après la légende ses deux pires amis
dont il est conscient l'honneur de deux
principaux dieux qui aurait créé et le
soleil et la lune mais aussi les hommes
du cinquième soleil soit les derniers
hommes techniquement fend la fin
définitive du monde
outre le côté très religieux de
l'endroit on ne sait absolument pas qui
a créé ce lieu symbolique soit ces
pyramides qui date d'au moins 200 ans
avant jésus-christ et c'est là que le
mystère entre en jeu pour rallier ceux
ci à indiana jones dans la continuité de
la saga ses pyramides aurait pu être
créée par des êtres suprême comme dans
le quatrième opus est là où je voulais
exactement vous amener et que nous ne
connaissons que très peu ce site
religieux
historique car d'après les recherches
cette cité sera souterraine à plus de
90%
ce que nous voyons en dehors ne
représenterait que 10% de la cité la
cité où les hommes se transforment en
dieu
voilà comment étaient représentés la
cité par les aztèques que referme ce
lieu symbolique et pourquoi les hommes
se transformerait en dieu si nous
revenons à indiana jones nous pourrions
potentiellement penser à un ennemi qui
souhaiteraient percer ce mystère et donc
acquérir ce mystérieux pouvoirs divins
pourquoi pas néanmoins comme vous le
savez indiana jones reste tout de même
une saga c'est fantastique
alliant plusieurs mystères à la fois et
si je vous parle de cette légende ce
n'est pas pour rien car comme je voulais
non ça auparavant
teotihuacan est une cité composé au
final majoritairement sous terre dont
nous ne savons rien un mystère pourrait
alors six cachets dont un très connue
celle de la théorie de la terre creuse
alors oui je sais qu'elle est beaucoup
réfutée par les scientifiques mais
indiana jones reste tout de même assez
fantastique pour en parler
teotihuacan pourrait être la porte vers
un autre monde souterrain inconnu à
l'homme jusqu'à maintenant et indiana
jones la découvrirait suite à plusieurs
mystère résolu auparavant en rapport ou
non aux être suprême
l'homme étant l'animal le plus évolué de
la terre se serait pourquoi il se
transformerait en dieu car l'homme ne
viendrait seigneur de l'endroit étant
inhabitée par lui-même justement indiana
jones devrait faire face à un ennemi qui
pourraient vouloir s'approprier
l'endroit pour en faire son monde
parfait où peut-être acquérir quelque
chose de mystérieux jones protégerait
alors l'endroit soit ce qu'ils
renferment et c'est un scénario qui
pourrait réellement se faire comme une
suite directe
ça me fait d'ailleurs pas mal penser aux
mystères de l'atlantide déjà repris dans
un jeu indiana jones
a vous de me dire ce que vous en pensez
[Musique]
pour cette dernière théorie j'ai envie
de partir sur quelque chose de plus
farfelues que les deux autres mais que
j'aimerais bien voir comme je le répéter
plusieurs fois le prochain indiana jones
devrait se passer dans les années 60 et
donc sur l'un des grands moments de
cette période
nous pourrions penser à l'assassinât de
john fitzgerald kennedy en 63 mais ce
n'est pas l'événement qui nous intéresse
nous sommes en pleine guerre froide et
les états unis et les soviétiques sont
en pleine rivalité sur tous les points
dont la conquête spatiale qui était un
sujet réellement important est au coeur
de la société dans les années 60 la
course à l'espace comme on l'appelle qui
des deux nations sera la plus avancée en
termes spatiale eh bien ce sont les
américains grâce à apollo 11 en 1969 qui
ont posé le premier homme sur la lune
c'est une date qui pourrait correspondre
à indiana jones 5 pourquoi pas et
franchement il y aurait matière à faire
indiana jones traite toujours des
grandes questions de ce monde des
mystères surnaturel la théorie du
complot comme quoi personne n'a été sur
la lune en 1969 pourraient être
exploitées par les soviétiques et créer
la zizanie
c'est une option nous n'avons jamais eu
réellement un indiana jones en rapport
avec l'espace et pourtant dieu sait
qu'il est l'endroit le plus mystérieux
de l'univers je ne compte pas réellement
l'épisode iv avec le crâne de cristal
car ce sont des êtres d'une autre
dimension dont il est question de plus
récemment plusieurs gros mystère font
surface à propos de la lune par rapport
justement à des photos prises par apollo
11 ans 69
on y voir est des bâtiments des
installations des constructions mais
elles ne sont pas créés par l'homme et
ses images ont été dévoilées récemment
ces photos proviennent de 1969 lors du
passage d'apollo 11 et qui sont restées
secrètes pendant tout ce temps la
question de notre solitude dans
l'univers a toujours été démentie par le
monde et ce mystère alliés apollo 11
pourrait être un très bon scénario pour
indiana jones 5
nous sommes en pleine guerre froide et
indiana jones vient de se marier avec
une marion ravenwood la conquête de
l'espace bat son plein et les etats-unis
et la russie ne se font aucun cadeau
l'amérique pose le premier pas sur la
lune et de nombreux mystères sont alors
découvert via ses photos les russes
découvrant les photos ferait leur
possible pour aller sur la lune le
découvrir
indiana jones pourrait faire partie de
l'expédition suite à plusieurs
péripéties ou bien un moyen de
téléportation pour aller sur la lune
existerait le film serait capable de
nous proposer quelque chose du genre
voulant avoir des réponses on verrait
ses fameux bâtiment sur la lune
les russes abusif moore est évidemment
et indiana jones en tirerait avec une
morale et la réflexion pour nous
spectateurs de la question de la vie
autres parcs sur terre enfin voilà ce 3
théorie était important pour moi et je
suis heureux d'enfin vous avoir pu le
proposer n'hésitez pas à les voir la
chaîne de mon ami aro sf qui fait des
vidéos théorie à peu près dans le même
style que moi il fait réellement un
super travail et ses vidéos sont
réellement passionnante
alors allez vous abonner à sa chaîne et
pour le coup on a eu droit à des
hypothèses à toutes les sauces
et c'est justement ce dont il va s'agir
dans la première partie de cette vidéo à
savoir qui sont les parents de rei
km je me souviens avoir voulu être
archéologue quand j'étais enfant je sais
maintenant et je suis même sûr de savoir
d'où ça vient
indiana jones est une saga qui faire
rêver et je suis content de l'avoir
rendu hommage merci à ce qu'il est soit
1 pouces bleus et qui partageront la
vidéo que le line up soit avec vous et à
oui si vous doutez par rapport à la
dernière théorie comme dirait jodie
foster d'un contact c'est vraiment
vraiment grand c'est plus grand que tout
ce que n'importe qui a jamais pu rêver à
ce jour alors s'il n'y a que nous
ça me semble a beau gâchis l'espace non
[Musique]